I'm an astronaut
I flew on the space shuttle twice and I
lived on the International Space Station
for almost six months
people often ask me the same question
which is what's it like in space as if
it was a secret and space belongs to all
of us and I'd like to help you
understand why it's a place that is
magic for all of us
the day after my 50th birthday I climbed
aboard a Russian capsule in Russia and
launched into space it's launching is
the most dangerous thing that we do and
it's also the most thrilling 3 2 1
liftoff
I felt every single bit of the
controlled fury of those rocket engines
as they blasted us off the earth
we went faster and faster and faster
until after eight and a half minutes on
purpose
those engines stopped kaboom
and we are weightless and the mission
and the magic begin Dmitri and Paolo and
I are circling the Earth in our tiny
spacecraft approaching the space station
carefully it's an intricate dance at
17,500 miles an hour between our capsule
the size of a smart car and the space
station the size of a football field we
arrive when those two craft dock with a
gentle funk we open hatches have zero
sloppy zero-g hugs with each other and
now we're six we're a space family an
instant family my favorite part about
living up there was the flying I loved
it it was like being Peter Pan it's not
about floating just the touch of a
finger can actually push you across the
entire space station and then you sort
of tuck in with your toes
one of my favorite things was drifting
silently through the space station which
was humming along at night I wondered
sometimes if it if it knew I was there
just smilin but sharing the wonder of
that with the crew was also part of what
was important to me
a typical day in space starts with about
perfect commute
I wake up cruise down the lab and say
hello to the best morning view ever it's
a really fast commute only thirty
Seconds and we never get tired of
looking out that window I think it
reminds us that we're actually still
very close to Earth our crew was the
second ever to use the Canadian robotic
arm to capture a supply ship the size of
a school bus containing about a dozen
different experiments and the only
chocolate that we would see for the next
four months now chocolate aside every
single one of those experiments enables
yet one more scientific question
answered that we can't do down here on
earth and so it's like a different lens
get allowing us to see the answers to
questions like what about combustion
what about what about fluid dynamic
dynamics now sleeping is delightful my
favorite I mean you could be upside down
right side up my favorite curled up in a
little ball and floating freely laundry
no we load our dirty clothes into an
empty supply ship and send it off into
space the bathroom everyone wants to
know it's hard to understand so I made a
little video because I wanted it I
wanted kids to understand that the
principle of vacuum saves the day and
that just a gentle breeze helps
everything go where it is supposed to
well in real life it does now recycling
of course so we take our urine we store
it we filter it and then we drink it and
it's actually delicious sitting around
the table eating food that looks bad but
actually tastes pretty good but it's the
it's
gathering around the table that's
important I think both in space and in
on earth because that's what cements a
crew together for me music was a way to
stay connected to the rest of the world
I played a duet with in between Earth
and space with Ian Anderson of Jethro
Tull on the 50th anniversary of human
spaceflight connecting to family was so
important I talked with my family almost
every day the whole time I was up there
and I would actually read books to my
son as a way for us just to to be
together so important now when the space
station would go over Massachusetts my
family would run outside and they would
watch the brightest star sailing across
the sky and when I looked down I
couldn't see my house but it meant a lot
to me to know that the people I loved
the most were looking up while I was
looking down so the space station for me
is the place where Mission and magic
come together the mission the work are
vital steps in our quest to go further
than our planet an imperative for
understanding sustainability here on
earth I loved being a part of that and
if I could have taken my family with me
I never would have come home and so my
view from the station showed me that we
are all from the same place we all have
our roles to play because the earth is
our ship space is our home and we are
the crew of spaceship earth thank you
[Applause]